let's make a rule that the minute the
guy comes up we can't be hitting
hey knock off hey damn it me con and
Sona she hit me just before you came up
it's not fair I saw it well I saw
it hello there Bill how are you oh I'm
great Bill uh I'm Conan this is Sona
that's uh it's David right David yeah
David's also I think you're coming from
Illinois aren't you I am yeah okay which
part of illo are you from uh winter
paror which is the northeast corner of
the state we border Wisconsin and Lake
Michigan okay cuz David I think you're
from the very very farthest part South
I'm from Carlinville closer to
Springfield oh I know where that's it
yeah yeah yeah no one really goes there
um come on well no they really it's fair
that's true right I wasn't putting you
down yeah no you weren't yeah it's the
only Dairy Queen franchise that's failed
in the United States no it's still open
it's still going but no one goes every
now and then an ear of corn rolls in act
like it's a customer
come on anyway Bill back to you you're
the focus here not my assistant who
comes from a cornfield um Bill tell us a
little bit about yourself what do you do
for a living uh I'm a police officer for
20 years police officer very very good
and uh what unit are you in what uh tell
us a little bit about your job as a
police officer well the the the town
that I live in is the town that I work
for um it's a small town so it's like
four four square miles we got about
6,000 people okay small town I grew up
here so um I I've been I was assigned as
a canine Officer for a number of years a
canine Officer yeah wow yeah I I
whenever I always love seeing uh a
working dog and I love seeing uh you
know police dogs I just love the idea
that that because I think correct me if
I'm wrong but I think dogs know when
they're working they know that they have
a job to do matter of fact I was just
talking to one of the other guys about
it I had to stop wearing my uniform home
because he would see me leaving in my
uniform and just try to bust out the
door with me you know so I I just
decided to start changing at work so
your dog retired he he is retired yeah
what's he doing now is he like building
model ships and has he tried has he
tried golf he's he's uh he's watching a
lot of the History Channel I believe oh
yeah yeah hey just do me a favor check
the liquor when you come home cuz it's
when they it's when they start day
drinking that you got to worry um well
what kind of dog uh is your dog that
just retired what's his name and what
kind of dog is he his name is Hondo he's
a pure German Shepherd oh cool they're
supposed to be very smart dogs he's he's
pretty smart oh I said very smart and
you said pretty smart he's pretty smart
okay yeah he he's hear he's hearing all
this right now and getting depressed
yeah can we see him can he can he come
up and yeah I want to see his uh face I
love to see it I love dogs don't you
want to see this guy Hondo Hondo Hondo
he can't hear us cause Hondo help help
I'm being robbed Hondo I'm going to try
and create a a crime so that what is he
going to do through the there he is
Hondo a what a gorgeous guy hi Hondo
yeah you've earned your retirement he
did he has earned it definitely that's
so funny I wonder if Hondo went through
some of the same tropes that people go
through in movie he's like well I'm
three days from
retirement oh no that squirrel has a
gun blam blam no I'm glad he's okay I'm
glad most in movies whenever a policeman
says well three days from retirement you
know that's when the hits the fan
that's excess yeah that was in uh what
was it Robert Deval movie yeah it's in
every movie it's in every police movie
ever made um let me ask you a question
if I can Bill how do you do you get to
pick any dog or they try to pair you
with the right dog your first day in
class um they've already got the dogs
set and there's usually four or five
officers in the class right um they've
the kennel the people that own the
kennel have already done all the
research on you they've they've done
your background they talked to your
police police chief your friends your
neighbors your family all without your
knowledge oh and they they find out what
kind of person you are and that's how
they pair up the dogs with you oh that's
sometimes sometimes they'll even change
you know midday or mid the mid the first
week they might see something that oh
this dog's not working with Bill so
we'll put him with Conan and Conan's
dog's gonna go with you know Sona and
blah blah blah blah blah this this makes
me I'm very curious about this so how
does how did they match Hondo with you
what qualities did they seeing you that
they saw in Hondo well fortunately this
is my third dog so and I got him later
in my career so I was uh at this point
on a nice even Keel and and I had
matured and and so I got I got the
mature dog I got the dog that was strong
but confident and calm oh I see so that
earlier in your career you might have
had a dog that was maybe a little bit
more of a hot shot a hote head I did I
had I had the Top Gun dog yeah he was he
was crazy I Lov him to death but yeah I
think think if I was a canine Officer
that'd pair me with a dog with very low
testosterone and and that was prone to
depression I think Chihuahua CH you be
the first Chihuahua police yeah it would
be a very depressed Chihuahua isn't that
what Irish seters
are I think that's very cool so Hondo
now uh is probably struggling a little
bit with um being retired he is um like
I said the first I this happened on
Memorial Day this year and so the first
couple weeks was pretty tough I was
wearing my uniform home and you know in
the morning I'd change and and I'd go
out to work and he would just try to
bust out the door here with me and I'd
be like no no you got to stay in the
house and uh I stopped wearing my
uniform home and that helped out
tremendously because he knew when it was
time to go to work I because I thrw my
uniform on hey why did Hondo have to
retire I mean uh what what are the signs
that it's time for your dog to retire so
early on in his career uh he got hit by
a car little accident that we had and he
broke his hip and he recovered fully
from it but the arthritis is starting to
kick in so getting a little doesn't like
to put his you know get up on stuff as
much as he used to my dad is 94 and I
hit him with a car about a week ago oh
first time I missed him but then I swung
around and I got him a second time throw
in Reverse yeah I got him anyway they
say he's going to mend up real good so
you're saying that's the same thing kind
of okay I think so yeah well that's
sounds like got your hands full with
that that's your full-time job is being
a police officer in the canine unit well
no more the canine unit now I'm just uh
I uh I run the Training Division and
scheduling and I still go on patrol and
answer calls every every now and then do
you ever see dogs that are just hanging
out and they look like they're up to no
good and you go over and talk to them
and say you know you could make
something of your life is that something
that would work where you the dog's like
smoking weed andu dog Corner this dog is
smoking weed
oddly enough I I don't know why dispatch
does this but every time we have a dog
calling a loose dog or a dog that just
bit somebody they send me you I hand the
dog guy I handled I handled a a dog that
was trained to do you know ungodly
things and I don't deal with dogs that
don't listen so thing is you can't give
up on a dog any dog can become a police
dog don't you believe that I I do
believe that I mean I've seen everything
from Chihuahua Pit Bulls Rottweilers
German Shepherds everything um even a
poodle you know to do some sort of
police work you know whether it be
finding drugs or finding Electronics you
know stuff like that I think poodles
mostly work in the lab they're like
they're looking at a microscope I have a
poodle I think she'd be a good police I
know you're poodle no your dog would not
you her dog wears a slash hat the same
hat that slash wears she thinks that's
funny it's cute your dog cannot be a
little scared of flies but I think she
could really do something oh sure yeah
scared of a fly and then of robber I
don't think
so